Hello everyone.
Any drugs?
Oh,
welcome to talks at Google today.
It is my pleasure to welcome Hugh Jackman,
Taryn Edgerton,
and at Dexter Fletcher for Eddie the Eagle.
Thank you all for being here.
So can you tell us a little bit about the story of Eddie Edwards?
Yeah,
uh,
I mean,
this one.
Yeah,
I've forgotten.
I think Edwards was a,
uh,
a British ski jumper back in 1988 who managed to get himself,
to the 1988 Calgary Olympics.
Um,
and he was profoundly untalented when it came to ski jumping bots.
He was full of lots of ambition and he was at a lifelong dream to be at the
Olympics and he got himself there.
So that's kind of loosely the story.
Anyone here old enough to remember?
Ada was Idi Amin?
Be Proud,
be proud guys.
Um,
so Tara,
you play Eddie in the film.
Yes.
What,
it was this great kind of character,
physical transformation for you.
Um,
what did you,
did you have any sort of rituals?
I'd for maybe carbs?
Yeah.
To prepare,
you know,
how'd you get into it?
Dedicated,
very,
very dedicated to pastry.
Um,
yes,
there was that.
I don't say he was such a kind of a character fall looking guy.
He had this very prominent um,
underbite under deep sonorous voice as I'm noticing that this it,
um,
yeah.
And he had like,
you know,
a ginger mustache.
Did you have what kind of coke bottle glasses?
It was just a great fun opportunity to try something wildly different.
Really.
Yeah.
Speaking of wildly different,
so who your character is fictional.
Yeah.
Um,
did you,
did you find it sort of liberating and having more room to play or was it a
little,
little intimidating and having to sort of create this,
this character who fits into this narrative that people are familiar with?
It's certainly easier creating a character when you have someone like Eddie
Edwards who I remember and suddenly everyone in England knows at least visually,
but there remember he's anti because it makes it much harder.
Not to mention for Taryn,
he watched the movie for the first time with the real guy.
Eddie Ed was an all his family and friends.
Now that is that kind of pressure,
that pressure.
Yeah.
Bump,
easy breezy.
And I played the,
a fictional coach,
uh,
has been on old,
has been sort of ski jumper who is now an alcoholic.
So I did a lot of research for that.
You also a character actor in this?
Yes.
I don't know if anyone knows ginger,
Ginger Baker or has seen a documentary.
You go edge and you're begging the drummer.
The drama.
Yeah.
So I based him on,
on Ginger Baker who to me was this kind of the epitome of rock and roll by the
way.
You should see this documentary.
Beware Ginger Baker.
He was a very,
very famous drama nine to be the greatest rock and roll drummer of all time.
But when he wasn't driving,
he was like basically almost killing himself in some way,
shape or form.
And if he hadn't a found drumming when he was 14,
he would've been in jail by the time he was 15.
And so he was pure,
pure rock and roll.
And that's who I kind of
basis character on.
Uh,
so Dexter,
yeah.
To know,
you know,
how,
how did this feel and get me because it'd been in development or there'd been
interest for a while and yeah,
you guys got it done.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well,
there's,
we have a great producer,
Brian,
the name of Matthew Vaughn,
who's also a great film director in his own right,
the towns work with on Kingsman.
He directs in Kingsman,
uh,
produce that as well.
And he's a,
uh,
an old friend of mine and he kinda dug out the script.
It had been sitting around for a long time,
but it takes someone like Matthew Vaughn who's,
um,
amount of vision,
who dug out the script and said,
hey,
look,
here's something really interesting for the siren and you to start tackling.
And I've been speaking to Hugh Jackman.
Right?
Okay,
this already sounds good.
So then we've got hold of the script and that was about two,
two years ago.
So it was really about two years ago when things really started to happen in
earnest.
And,
uh,
Eh,
like any film,
it's certain amount of alchemy.
Alchemy is involved,
you know,
and,
and the right things have to come together in order to create that magic moment.
And,
and this just happens to be one of those magic moments.
Hello everybody.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's just,
you know,
things have to sort of all come together and the stars have to align and uh,
and yeah,
and we will have a good experience.
Can you,
Jacqueline has to be free.
That's really when it came down to got it done.
We'd like the Hugh Jackman for 15 years.
Suddenly you've got a six week window.
We grabbed it.
Um,
so speaking of magic moments,
I feel like the,
the 88 Olympics were just the sort of,
you know,
it was,
it was Eddie's story.
It was the Jamaican bobsled team.
Yeah.
And I'm curious if you guys think,
um,
you know,
we live in sort of this age of viral illness and,
and uh,
you know,
there's an instant spotlight,
but in the,
in the 80s,
it wasn't necessarily that,
you know,
but the Olympics around the few events that everyone watches.
Yeah.
Do you think any story,
like if he was ski jumping today would have as much heart or,
or which I think is like a compliment to him as a person or,
um,
do you think
I would wonder Robin.
I don't know what I mean,
the thing about it then was the,
it took time for that story to reach around the world and it sort of grew and
built and built my men.
Um,
you know,
and I think it was the information was coming from another side of the world and
it took longer to get back.
And so I suppose the as boy longevity in that way that,
you know,
it's kind of more in the consciousness cause you've got to really seek out
whether it's,
it's so it's not that it's so quick and you swipe it away and that's it.
It's gone.
It's a quick thing.
It sort of hangs around and things lingered for longer.
Well,
you know,
catches,
I goes,
I was in Australia,
I remember we were all kind of transfixed by him.
And you know,
in the closing ceremony he's kind of mentioned by one summer.
I just,
they go on here.
Right.
He,
he,
he was on Johnny Carson flew him down and,
uh,
there's a great clip if you to see it,
a youtube of him on Johnny Carson with Burt Reynolds and Burt Reynolds is an
aura of this guy,
Eddie Edwards.
And he's,
this is going from Cheltenham,
England on Johnny Carson.
He said he's very funny.
And yeah,
it kind of caught this cause I think it was such an unusual thing.
He was very much the every man doing this crazy,
crazy sport.
It was subtle.
This is before we extremely extreme sports existed,
but ski jumping is basically an extreme sport where people die all the time,
but it really did capture their,
yeah,
yeah.
I probably only would have been more today,
I reckon.
Hmm.
Um,
one of the things I love is that it,
yeah,
I think the movie tells me that his whole story,
he,
it's like you don't have to win to be a winner.
Um,
I think he's,
you know,
it's very earnest story and it's nice to see somebody who succeed at their
dream,
even though their dream is,
it's,
they're reaching for the stars,
but it's not necessarily over analysis reaching for stars and that it's not,
I want to put you in a gold medal Olympian is I wanted to be an Olympian.
Um,
so we're curious if there's any sort of moments in your own lives that you feel
like,
hey,
this was really personally important to me.
You know,
other people might not necessarily see it as the same level of achievement,
but,
oh,
that's a good question.
Was when did it get to the Google headquarters?
Woo.
Uh,
uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I suppose we would have those moments in our lives.
you know,
what defines Eddie is that he has this kind of unwavering self belief and that
gets him to where he wants to go.
And I think that's what's the interesting mess.
Part of the,
one of the many messages that this bill Maher's but I think what's so strong
about it is that you know how you have that belief in yourself and it's,
and then see how far that gets you because you will be beset with many doubters
and your own self doubt.
But if you can just take it that bit further,
you will end up at Google headquarters.
You know what I mean?
It's,
that's part of what it is.
That's a,
that can take you so far.
And Yeah,
I love what you said actually.
I've sort of been saying exactly the same thing.
Copying a friend of mine who saw the movie that you don't have to win to be a
winner.
And I think kids often today,
if you asked him,
you know who their role models are,
they,
it's,
you know,
Larry or Sergei or a Steve jobs or it's,
Lebron James is this people that Uber achievers in life and,
and I'm like,
mom,
that's great.
But you know,
very few people can achieve that level of perceived success.
But that doesn't mean you're not a winner if you don't get there,
you know.
And what about the firemen or what about the school teacher,
what about that?
And I mean this is probably going to sound a bit like self promotion in a way,
but I do this,
uh,
you ask him,
you know,
what things in our life,
and I was lucky enough to go on a trip with world vision to Ethiopia and I met
her a coffee farmer,
uh,
called Duke Carly and cut a long story short,
about three years later we opened up a cafe in two cafes in New York and we sell
Espresso Code to college dream.
And every time I walked into this cafe,
which is about the size of their coffee table there and I just get a flat wide
and I know that all the profits in that are sort of directly and we buy beans
from him directly and give him fair trade prices and all that.
Somehow that makes me just feel fantastic.
It's a small little cafe in,
in a city filled with cafes.
But it gives me a kind of feeling that is as great as anything I've done.
Yeah,
yeah.
Follow that.
Yeah,
go ahead.
We'll go.
Is
Always,
always wanted to be a Google hair gray.
The reason I've been so quiet this far is because this is really is quite a
moment
here.
There's some amazing restaurants here.
Is the Vegan restaurant open?
No,
I,
that's what,
we can make it open.
We will open it today.
I don't know really things that were important to me that didn't seem as
important as everyone else.
I don't know.
I think,
you know,
the,
the big thing in my life was probably getting into drama school when I was about
19 and,
but that was very important to my family as well.
So that was really lame answer,
isn't it?
I'm trying to think of anything more interesting.
But yeah,
that was,
that was the sort of big thing in my life that felt like a real kind of
insurmountable challenge.
And in fact,
the first year I tried it was,
they didn't look at me twice,
but yeah,
second year I got in,
sorry.
Yes.
There we go.
There you go.
Um,
so I'd love to talk about,
you guys had a great sort of on,
on through chemistry and it's,
it's a very sort of intimate film,
you know,
it's very,
it's two characters and it's kind of first it's you versus the world and then
it's youtube versus the world.
Um,
what was the onset experience like?
Always.
Yeah.
We don't get,
we don't talk anymore.
It's amazing.
This in yesterday,
Joe,
Joe Friends,
I mean,
very tense.
Do,
would start every day with the same,
same goal and give it to them.
Let's make a movie every morning we'd walk on the sad side of animal and make us
laugh and everyone would clap and we get going.
And I,
this man is one of the funniest,
most talented man I've ever worked with it.
And uh,
we just had a blog.
I had a blast.
Oh No,
I did have a blast.
Basically.
Was,
there was,
there was a pause there.
I basically made it my mission when I started this film.
I have to when you first meet here,
he's so approachable and kind of intimidating.
Won't let you look him in the eye.
But um,
but so friendly and lovely.
Yeah,
I completely completely took advantage of this.
So what I did was I made it my aim making this film to try and make Hugh Jackman
laughing every take
possible.
So they were the detriment of the film completely.
And I don't care.
So we'd start and do seeds that the camera turned around on him and I'd be in
the middle of a scene and I just sort of decide to pull a funny face or the
exaggerated Eddie face I like to call it,
which is something like this.
Okay.
Would immediately crack up every time.
Oh,
I loved it.
Every second of it.
There's already,
give me one of the really,
really funny,
there's a really fun game you can play watching this movie and I need to name
actually maybe it was called it like a drinking game.
Like it's a good drinking game.
So we'll call it [inaudible] Perry.
I'm the game is,
is that cues character laughing or is that just a few crops and I think you will
never use it as to yeah,
you'd be quite drunk
at the end of it.
Um,
so I have a few rapid fire questions for all of you.
Uh,
what sport do you think should be in the Olympics that isn't already
golf?
Wow,
that was fast.
I actually can't think of a single sport at the moment.
And drone racing.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'd like to see some seriously fast medic drone racing and we go,
yeah,
we could have our first Olympian in that city right here.
Put me sitting in this room,
that person today,
he's got a drone at home and weren't.
Okay.
Think of a spool.
That's how little of a sports where I am.
I can't think of one sport.
Okay.
That's not already in the Olympics.
Pogo stick video games.
Three legged race.
Um,
so Eddie's mom has this adorable sort of sweet bull jumper a that says the,
I am editing
mom.
What would your wool jumper say?
I've got one.
Oh,
says I play Eddie.
So,
ah,
I have,
I really off.
Someone made it for me and I love it.
And they may go with my mum as well,
so I'm at that says I met his mom could have a single for there
deal breaker.
Nobody else has a jumper idea.
Sometimes you go,
thank you.
Just let that one hang in here.
What,
or a song,
what would your theme song be in the film?
In life.
Oh,
okay.
She's a mania.
Very good.
It is.
The competition
isn't,
it is actually speaking of music.
I do I have to ask,
um,
the song at the end?
Yes.
You guys want to talk about though?
Yeah.
Matthew,
Matthew Vaughn,
the producer and decks,
the,
the soundtrack is fantastic.
If you like eighties music,
if you hate me,
these music,
you'll hate the sound,
but it's really,
you want me,
he's lying now.
It's really,
it's really fantastic.
And so he wanted to have a call song for the,
for the ending.
And so when out to a whole bunch of bands and Gary Barlow and orchestral
maneuvers in the dark,
OMD came up with this song.
They did write it together,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
And then,
uh,
they were going to perform it and because the real idiot was as they do anyone,
if anyone gets any notoriety that he recorded a single,
does that have any really,
but in England it goes to number one.
Okay.
And this is the country,
was it nearly the elephant that went to number one?
We have exquisite.
So
Eddie did once.
So Taryn Sang the lead on the bandwagon as well.
No,
that's not,
you got from the back and I did the backing vocals for it and we've seen this,
uh,
this song,
which if you watch,
do the credits,
you,
you can check it out.
Sort of an eighties pop song,
isn't it called gold thrill me.
Yeah.
The,
I just felt it was a fun thing to do.
You know,
that it was just,
it was in and he were very gracious and very keen and,
and went in the studio and recorded his bit in London.
And you are in Australia,
Australia,
the bills and because we weren't talking at the time,
that's why you couldn't have them in the same room.
Can the same contemplate that bad?
Can I tell a little song?
I'm going to embarrass you now.
Can I get to tell the story?
Because he'd lay down,
he'd go there anyway.
So
have you looked at me and said,
don't
really.
Anyway,
so uh,
he,
he had already done it and they sent it over.
I said,
it's just fantastic.
I was speaking to,
Matthew said,
yeah,
Taryn came in.
Gary Barlow is here.
Do you guys know Gary Barlow?
He's very,
very famous English.
So he was performing what was his band
and now writes on his own anyway,
so he knows what he's doing.
And so Taryn came in and apparently he said,
okay,
if you want to go into the booth to really interrogates,
yeah.
Do you want me to do it like an 80 style or kind of carries like,
Gary was like,
okay,
like not knowing.
He goes,
I'm just wondering if this guy can sing little eyes.
And he saw and he said,
he went in there and Matthew Vaughn said to Gary goes,
Carey,
he's better than you.
And it was phenomenally.
I was there.
It was amazing.
You two seem to enjoy seeing.
So Dexter,
and to ask you this,
if you could direct them in a musical,
what would it be?
Oh,
I was just watching a little bit of singing in the rain with which I love seeing
it in the right.
It would be great.
But then they started singing a w not Philadelphia story being in at high risk
high society.
That would be their choice.
I'd love to though.
I haven't got the feet first.
He's roses,
roses.
It's fine.
The mom May,
are you doing
Friday?
All I'm thinking about it is that first of all
I already had as this one was singing,
is the Google bus to local by the way?
Yes it is.
Yes.
It
will take a few in a second or stay exactly where you are.
Your choice.
Um,
what,
uh,
what do you hope audiences will take away from this film?
So I think we will,
we always felt like we wanted to create something that was just uplifting and
fun and uncynical and not kind of trying to be Trixie or dark or edge in any
way.
It's just,
no,
go ahead.
You're right.
I'm sorry.
Did I say no,
no,
no.
Just that we wanted it to be really,
um,
really,
yeah,
really uplifting.
And for people to leave the theater with a spring in their step.
And I hope I got to people feel,
it's certainly the way I felt when I first watched it.
Anyway,
you kind of reminded me of the full Monte when I read it.
You know,
it's got that grading which target naked in it.
Yeah.
There's one dude saying,
well,
you're not dude,
I,
I'm sort of moving,
oh gosh,
naked.
Oh Gosh.
Nude.
I'm fine.
Physical shirt.
And it kind of sneaks up on you,
the film.
And people do really end up leaving with a smile on their face and a happy and,
and again,
more.
My friend said,
which I'm a parent and really is a great film to show kids or your kids.
It's a great message for them,
I think,
you know.
Yeah.
I absolutely what the guy said,
you know,
we want people to come out feeling good and,
and,
and having a good experience and feeling like,
Hey,
tomorrow maybe I'll tackle something that I've been putting off for a while.
I don't know.
That's a big thing,
but also just to understand how dangerous these,
this ski jumping is.
You know what these guys do and it's trying to capture that sense of danger and
fear of someone at the top of a nightly meter ski jump who still then goes for
it and still takes that on.
You know,
there's,
there's lots of excitement in that and um,
yeah,
there's,
there's many wonderful things to take away from the film.
Mostly a ticket for your friend I think to take away.
Hey guys,
thanks for coming in to Google today.
I got a question for Terry [inaudible] he was going to sing.
I can sing if you guys want.
It wouldn't be to privilege.
Um,
you were just talking about how it's one of the scariest sports in the Olympics,
right?
It's absolutely crazy.
It's mind blowing when you watch it on TV.
It must be one of the most intense things that you could possibly do.
So,
Taryn,
did you give it a try?
Ski Jumping?
Yup.
Are you his slopes guy?
Uh,
should I buy level with you before we started making this movie,
I'd never been on a pair of skis in my life.
So for me,
learning to ski was enough of a challenge.
And the moment an actor in a movie,
he says,
okay,
I'm going to do my own ski jumping.
The gods of insurance descend and smash you into the ground.
So,
um,
actually I was weirdly,
I was totally fine with not doing,
we're gonna see jumping.
I don't know why
you,
you
just arrived.
I was,
I'm gonna do it.
That's what Matt and then he got to the top of the job.
There is no flipping way that it is absolutely crazy.
Attos,
Tom Cruise,
get insurance for his movies.
I have no idea.
I was,
like I said,
the Dexter Tom Cruise,
it's hung cruise or do the jump.
He would do it.
He probably would,
I said challenge.
This is going on the Internet.
Hi.
Thanks for coming.
Um,
so my favorite character in the movie is Janet,
his mom.
Um,
and I'm wondering is she still alive and how'd you get my material for Joe to
play a character?
She said yes,
that is real.
Mum is still a still around there and did in fact many jumpers with different
slogans and various members of the family.
Um,
we pry around with the facts a bit in the film because it's,
it's a story that we're telling and I,
but she did actually end up in Calgary as well,
a newspaper flu.
It is parents out there and surprised him,
which I didn't really feel was,
it was a tough thing for ready at that time.
But suddenly,
you know,
his mom and dad turned up and some girlfriend that he'd had,
and they try to create this big drama.
So I stayed away from that.
But his mom,
his mom and dad is still around and uh,
and they've seen the film with Eddie,
um,
that I love that place screening.
Yeah.
That and I love it.
But,
uh,
Joe is just,
it's a lovely actress.
Yeah.
She's a fantastic actress.
I feel personally that was kind of the sort of beating heart of the movie in
some ways,
isn't she?
She's absolutely lovely performance.
It's my favorite character too.
Yeah.
I think your mom and dad are important because they're the heart of the home,
you know?
And,
and that's important that we understand where we're,
he comes from and you know,
and dad's a bit of a tougher carrots of Bersanti.
It's just out of fear for his,
his son,
you know,
he's just,
he's trying to protect him in a different way and mum's trying to encourage him
and of course those two forces pull against each other.
And,
um,
but she's always been there from the beginning.
She,
yeah.
She's,
she's great,
sir.
Thank you.
Speaking of tougher characters,
uh,
Hugh,
your character has a sort of shadow over his sort of career.
Yeah.
It's played by Mr Christopher Walken.
What that like having him as your sort of,
we found out about two weeks into filming.
Yeah.
Uh,
that,
uh,
my coach,
we played by Christopher Walken and we were just jumping around and there's a
one a moment I won't never forget.
Obviously when he did the scene with us in the,
in the locker room,
it was,
he's walked in.
So cool.
So common,
everyone went silent.
Right,
which is actually the way it's written in the script,
but the,
he shot the commentating scene before that and Tara and I had finished shooting
and we stuck around cause we wanted to go and see him work and I'll never forget
standing there.
Christopher Walken sort of up there in this commentating booth and we are sort
of hidden so he can't see us at the booth and is there and we're watching the
monitor and indexing and all of us is like an action
or I caught it.
Fantastic.
And he does a great walking impression.
Yeah.
Unfortunately it was.
And because of in the moment Christopher was cast,
he was basically in a Christopher Walken and post all day for all day.
We're going to roll them now
the movie.
But he started doing it to Christopher Walken without realizing
Chris,
we've got to do it again.
You're gray.
I love you.
I love it.
But we're going again.
You're a navigator.
Those
you've got to eat.
He has one line.
It is five words,
and in the middle is five word line.
Yeah.
He puts a 15 second pause in the middle of a five word line and it's brilliant.
No one else could pull that thing up.
I mean,
honestly,
Julie,
give us a little,
I'll,
I'll read the script three times and then if I like it,
I'll do it.
That's what he said.
If there's a,
a a better twice.
I got one more time.
I'll see how it goes.
You Jack.
When I like him,
good.
I don't think there's a better endorsement for this film and what I said.
So,
um,
Eddie,
the Eagle is going to be in theaters and thank you so much for joining.
Hey,
thank you for coming weekend.